[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à barcelone le real madrid joue sa coupe
d'europe devant le football club de
barcelone real madrid tout blanc vêtue
comme il est de tradition qui pour la
première fois depuis quelques années ne
se présente pas en champions mais en
challenger
c'est pourtant le catalan vergès qui
marque le premier but
le real cependant croit encore à la
victoire en deuxième mi-temps les
madrilènes prennent résolument la
direction des opérations
lens attaque sur attaque comme celle ci
qui se heurte à l'impitoyable défense de
barcelone on joue à 100 à l'heure sur ce
terrain les catalans repart toujours à
une vitesse extraordinaire au moment
précis où l'on croit que c'est le real
qui va marquer pour gagner il faut de la
chance le real n'en a pas c'est au
contraire barcelone qui ajoute un
nouveau but à son avantage par evariste
[Applaudissements]
le real madrid sait désormais qu'il ne
gagnera pas cette année la coupe
d'europe ce n'est pas le but marqué en
fin de partie par canario qui change
quoi que ce soit à l'issue du match le
real est battu c'est barcelone qui
représentera l'espagne en quarts de
finale de la coupe d'europe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au moment où l'on se penche sur les
sources artistique du 20e siècle
jetons un regard sur nancy mais au delà
des grilles de jean lamour nancy à une
place dans l'art moderne un nom d'abord
gagner c'est le nom c'est un galet en
effet le verdier galets qui fait le
créateur est l'âme de ce mouvement qui
donne à un nouveau tour au décor de la
vie et s'inspirant de la nature
donna naissance à ce qu'on en a bientôt
art floral et modern style
avec lui des ébénistes vallat et
majorelle donnèrent naissance à ces
mobiliers qui firent tour à tour
l'engouement et le dégoût de générations
successives
ce fut l'école de nancy elle ne devait
pas s'arrêter au mobilier en effet des
architectes intervenait à leur tour
on leur doit sans doute ses fantaisies
naturaliste qui font sourire aujourd'hui
[Musique]
à leur actif au contraire il faut noter
que la des imitations stériles et des
formules traditionnelles
il essayait de trouver en s'appuyant sur
la nature une espèce de baroque fans
siècle une sorte de gothic déformé
interpréter dont les exemples se voit
nombreux dans les rues de nancy et n'est
pas si rare d'en trouver également à
paris car faire de l'école de nancy une
école d'art local serait à la fois
injuste et inexact
elle atteignait on peut le dire
aujourd'hui le rang du style est le plus
beau titre de gloire qu'on puisse
décerner à l'école de nancy est
peut-être d'avoir avec des entrées du
métro données pourrait-on dire son
blason à la belle époque
avec ces accords tu porte drapeau le
défilé très officielle qui s'est
déroulée à travers mexico suffirait a
prouvé à ceux qui en douteraient que le
mexique est une nation groupement
sportif
[Musique]
mais tel n'était pas le but spécifique
de cet imposant déploiement d'athlètes
ouvert comme on voit toutes les
disciplines sans restriction ni
exclusive mexico avait en effet dédié
cette parade de souvenirs de celui qu'on
nomme là bas l'apôtre de la révolution
francisco madero dont l'action biffins
voici cinquante ans au règne du
dictateur porfirio diaz
[Musique]
atmosphère de nouveaux dramatique à
léopoldville ou le départ de
l'ambassadeur du ghana monsieur
houellebecq a été les pilotes d'une
bataille rangée entre les troupes de
l'onu et celle du colonel mobutu trois
morts d'un côté cinq de l'eau colonel
mobutu a présidé au milieu du cortège
des pleureuses aux obsèques des
militaires congolais tués dans le combat
parmi lesquels se trouvait le colonel
kokolo 200 mille congolais assure
léopoldville assistaient à ces obsèques
l'atmosphère surchauffée avait pu faire
craindre le pire
néanmoins c'est dans le calme que les
funérailles se sont déroulées
à l'elysée mise en train accélérée du
plan pour l'algérie du général de gaulle
monsieur louis joxe quitte le conseil
des ministres avec un portefeuille
nouvellement créé celui de ministre
d'état pour les affaires algériennes
le lendemain à alger le palais d'été
reçoit un nouvel hôte monsieur jean
morin qui succède à monsieur de
l'ouvrier au poste de délégué général
et l'on annonce le référendum pour
janvier
à rome où l'avaient précédé quelques
jours plus tôt monsieur macmillan
le premier ministre monsieur michel
debré est venu s'entretenir à son taux
des principales questions
internationales avec monsieur fanfani
président du conseil italien pacte
atlantique rapport est ouest désarmement
[Applaudissements]
au banc d'essai vous incite heroes 2
dont on peut voir la surface couverte de
cellules photo électriques destinés à
capter l'énergie solaire
quiros 2 c'est le deuxième satellite
météorologique lancée par les américains
à cap canaveral au sommet d'une fusée
delta muni entre autres instruments de
bord de deux caméras de télévision
l'engin devait être placé sur une orbite
pratiquement circulaire à 650 km de la
terre
pendant trois mois les radars vont
prendre en charge sans désemparer ce
poste d'observation de l'espace pour
capter les images enregistrées par ses
caméras à chacune de ses rotations
[Musique]
tireuse de après son prédécesseur tir au
sein doit apporter aux experts de la
météorologie la possibilité de disposer
d'une multitude de vue des grands
systèmes nuageux qui se forme autour de
la terre il ouvre ainsi la voie aux
prévisions météorologiques à l'échelle
de la planète
[Musique]
il est sans doute abusive de poser la
question trieste n'est ni à vendre ni à
céder
et le fait est que trieste ne représente
plus et de loin ce qu'elle représentait
naguère il n'est que de considérer ces
quais vides sont encore vacants pour
penser à une ville mans même les efforts
tentés pour rajeunir le port célèbre
n'ont servi à rien les nouveaux docks
sont vides comme les anciens et les
normes outillage tout neufs reste
inutile l'herbe hendaye et la voie
ferrée qui desservaient un immense
arrière pays
quant à la ville elle sommeil les
grosses d'affairé mig les immeubles qui
abritait le siège de grandes compagnies
ne loge plus que des agences et dans son
décor où s'inscrit toujours là grâce un
peu lourde du baroque autrichien puisque
trieste fut autrichienne pendant plus de
cinq cents ans
le visiteur ne retrouve au lieu de loder
un peu forte des plaques tournantes
économiques et commerciales que le
parfum fans et des gloires évolué et des
destins manqué miramar il est vrai n'est
pas si loin
[Musique]
pourtant on s'est battu pour trieste de
45 à 54 pendant près de dix ans italiens
et yougoslaves se sont disputés cette
pièce maîtresse de l'adriatique
population italienne contre économie
yougoslave sentiment italien contre
intérêt yougoslave
tout cela s'est terminé en 54 au profit
des couleurs italiennes
mais cette option mais cette cession ne
résolvait plus le problème pendant cette
période
l'histoire avait donné en effet deux
rivales à trieste venise et rijeka
trieste qui avait été le débouché de
l'immense empire autrichien le grand
marché et le grand terminus de
l'adriatique n'était plus qu'un cul de
sac au fond de son golf
cerné par des frontières à la limite de
ses faubourgs
quelques kilomètres à peine la sépare de
la yougoslavie mais pour l'italie elle
n'est plus qu'une marche lancée en
pointe car l'italie dans la crainte de
voir trieste devenir yougoslave a
transformé venise avec les dote de
margairaz elle en a fait son grand port
adriatique et le déversoir vers l'orient
de la lombardie agricoles et industriels
venise s'est retrouvé avec ses
installations modernes et l'ampleur de
ces nouveaux quais à nouveau reine de la
mer de l'autre côté la yougoslavie dans
la crainte aussi de perdre trieste seat
est de créer un nouveau grand or pour
ces débouché sur la mer
rijeka qu'on nommé fuel autrefois et qui
fut le théâtre du célèbre épisode
guerriers de d'annunzio est devenu
aujourd'hui sans rapport avec son passé
puisque sa population est passé en dix
ans de cinquante trois mille habitants
ascending entre venise et rijeka le rôle
de trieste est il terminé ou reste-t-il
un espoir un espoir qui s'appellerait
l'autriche priest pourrait-elle
redevenir pour l'autriche ce point de
contact avec la mer qu'elle ne possède
plus sous forme de port franc par
exemple et l'autoroute qui relie trieste
à l'autriche est elle une indication
aussi bien que les inscriptions qui
fleurissent les murs jusqu'à innsbruck
[Musique]
priest agonise de chômage et d'inaction
faudra-t-il que trieste 9
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]